[Music]
apprentice Ship can't be explained in words, but I
've only been in NY for 11 years, but
it seems like I've been chasing the back of the sushi who showed me how to live.
I think it's what life is and what it means to live
[Music]
Well, my name is Nakazawa. It
's a head chef-type corner in Nakazawa, New York.
I was planning to open a store together for the first time because he was talking about doing it together,
but now he is an electrician and I am 9 to New York.
What is New York style?
Edo-mae It is connected to New York-mae to make sushi that suits the tastes of New York customers in the United States while using the technology centered on the above.
I don't know anything about sushi, so I'd like you to show me everything from the time I cut off that head. I ca
n't
say goodbye with the live button.
Well, the maximum promise of American customers and Japanese technology is in
the middle.  I'm working for that.
Well, first of all, I had never eaten California rolls in
the United States. Until I came to the United States,
Identify Spicy Mayonnaise Net is live
scallops.
If it's a regulation, I'm
going to take root because I want to take root in the Boo Boo culture. Japan in the e-type
is a fish house Keio
tape type
sushi here.
Aru Udo
Passport Borappi my finger Tenrai Grab Taaaaa Pesh
club life
Boo Boo se 4 p Crane Fave Ooh sushi Eater is powder 1
Traveling
Ai-chan Check space and sushi eye can double pace o ring  It's good.
Soiso is abc on Mt. Tsukuba.
I bring pou dou dou, so I think I can be a busy mom for 5 to 6 years
.
of  It was a policy of parents of the Koro family
not to let their children eat too expensive food, and for me at that time,
inclusion was an egg and an environment bonus.
Even though I've spent my life as a client, I
've only used it for 178 years, so even if I compare it there, the experience points are completely
different.
]